california can expect another day of
severe fire danger more strong winds are
likely to whip up a pair of fast-moving
wildfires
just south of los angeles they've
already forced more than 90 thousand
people
to leave their homes jonathan vigliotti
is at the fire scene in
irvine california good morning to you at
times it felt like we were standing in
the middle of a category 2 hurricane and
believe it or not the wind has actually
calmed down overnight
giving fire crews a chance to focus on
hot spots like this before this fire
jumps over this roadway
the wind is expected to pick back up
later this morning
two wind-driven wildfires continue to
threaten thousands of homes in orange
county
firefighters kept a close watch on
shifting embers throughout the night
hoping to protect nearby neighborhoods
the silverado fire which started monday
morning shut down freeways
and forced evacuations
i have some place to go thankfully um
i got a dog to worry about now
dusts nearing 100 miles per hour meant
there was no air support to fight the
flames
the winds toppled big rigs as
firefighters appeared to struggle to
stay on their own feet
there is a neighborhood believe it or
not on the other side of all this
that fire crews right now simply can't
get to
two firefighters are hospitalized with
second and third degree burns
they were working near what we call the
heel of the fire where the fire had
started
we don't have any information on what
occurred
they're gravely injured their families
are with them
meanwhile firefighters worked to save
homes at the so-called blue ridge fire
about
five miles to the north flames crept
down hillsides
as officials went door to door making
sure homeowners
had safely evacuated and cameras
captured at least
one rescue a firefighter snatching a
small
injured rabbit from beneath a freeway
underpass
and bringing the animal to safety
and it's still unclear what sparked this
fire southern california edison one of
the main utility companies here
says wind could have damaged some of
their infrastructure sparking this blaze
the red flag warnings remain in effect
through this afternoon
back to you jonathan thank you
firefighters doing an amazing job there